ray pour en débattre nous sommes nous
avec pierre jeantet remaniant
radiologues et président de l'uar ps
auvergne rhône-alpes bonsoir pierre-jean
interne a mis en berne a mis en jeu par
demande merci d'être avec nous christian
prudhomme à vos côtés porte parole des
médecins urgentistes de france bonsoir
christian prudhomme merci d'être là
la vaccin pardonnez moi ça christophe
l'homme oui excusez moi c'est autant
pour moi effectivement la vaccination
christophe prudhomme donc la vaccination
des enfants et des adolescents
est-ce qu'il permettra selon vous de
réduire cette circulation virale dans la
population et en ce sens c'est ce
qu'elle est nécessaire selon le médecin
urgentiste que vous êtes et christophe
prudhomme non pour l'instant elle n'est
absolument pas nécessaire
aucune preuve pour l'instant
scientifiques montrent qu'il ya
nécessité de vacciner les enfants il
faut vacciner la population adulte nous
sommes déjà très en retard sur cette
vaccination première éléments et puis le
problème qui est plus important que la
vaccination des enfants dans les pays
riches et la vaccination de l'ensemble
de la population mondiale aujourd'hui on
vaccine essentiellement dans les pays
riches
or le virus ne connaît pas les
frontières les murs et si on ne vaccine
pas massivement la population adulte
déjà dans un premier temps sur
l'ensemble de la planète nous risquons
l'émergence de variants qu'ils peuvent
revenir vers le pays des vaccinés et qui
peuvent effectivement rendre cette
vaccination inefficaces avec la
nécessité d'une nouvelle dose
donc c'est passé pas la priorité
aujourd'hui seul autant que le rapport
bénéfice risque pour les enfants est un
rapport collectif alors apporte demi
positif collectif mais absolument pas
individuel comme pour les autres
maladies infectieuses qui tuaient les
enfants en bas âge il ya encore quelques
années qu'ils continuent à les tuer dans
des pays pauvres
pierre magnan d'accord avec ce biais
au stick et surtout cette approche de la
vaccination des enfants de christophe
prudhomme oui tout à faire je rejoins ce
que dit mon confrère
on n'a pas de certitude sur le fait que
lorsqu'on est vaccinée on n'est pas
porteur sain ou pas on n'a pas de
d'éléments froid la grand
donc si vous vacciner une population
d'enfants d'abord tourné quasiment
jamais malade vous êtes coincé puisque
vous ne pouvez pas vacciner la
population générale vous la pénurie de
vaccins dont il faut d'abord vacciner
les personnes qui sont à risque les plus
âgés et là je le rejoins on est très en
retard en france on ne protège pas les
autres populations
et puis surtout c'est qu'on n'a pas une
idée précise de la durée de la
protection par le vaccin
donc avant de s'occuper des enfants
éventuellement s'ils ont démontré qu'ils
restauraient on va dire porteur en étant
vacciner pour l'instant c'est vraiment
pas à l'ordre du jour
alors avant de vous redonner la parole
christophe prudhomme je voudrais vous
faire écouter cet avis qui nous vient de
l'institut pasteur sur la vaccination
des enfants
si seuls les adultes sont vaccinés une
épidémie importante et malgré tout
attendu chez les enfants
contribuant à l'infection des parents et
des grands parents non protégés s'il est
démontré que les vaccins sont sûrs chez
les enfants et qu'ils réduisent
efficacement la susceptibilité dans
cette population
la vaccination de 60 69 % des 0 64 ans
est de 90 % des plus de 65 ans pourrait
permettre le relâchement complet des
mesures de contrôle alors effectivement
une épidémie qui reviendrait c'est bien
cela christophe prudhomme à en croire
l'institut pasteur
si on ne vaccine pas les enfants écouter
tous ces modèles mathématiques depuis le
début de l'épidémie ont montré leurs
limites
il est toujours intéressant d'utiliser
ces modèles mathématiques pour évaluer
le pire
heureusement le pire n'a jamais été là
donc pour l'instant
j'insiste un taxi non plus rapidement
cent de la population c'est moi je suis
médecin urgentiste je travaille avec mes
collègues réanimateurs j'ai moi même
travaillé en réanimation
l'urgence aujourd'hui est de vacciner la
population adulte parce que tout retard
à cette vaccination ce sont des malades
en plus en réanimation et des morts en
plus c'est ça la priorité
il ya aucun mort chez les enfants pour
l'instant et si vous savez pour
l'instant on ne sait pas ce qui se passe
chez les enfants on nous a dit à un
moment donné et qu'ils étaient des
supers contaminateur est en fête a
ensuite que ce n'était pas le cas si
effectivement il y avait un danger avec
les enfants nous aurions eu des
catastrophes dans les écoles ce qui n'a
pas été le cas
qui plus est les dernières études
montrent que c'est plutôt les parents
qui contamine les enfants que le
contraire donc si les parents sont
vaccinés il ya peu de chances que les
enfants soient contaminés donc
contaminants pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune certitude scientifique et
j'assiste le problème et vous avez votre
présentation évoqué la levée des brevets
sur des vaccins
l'urgence aujourd'hui est au delà de la
levée sur les vaccins de pouvoir
identifier les entreprises qui peuvent
les usines qui peuvent produire ces
vaccins et leur donner les moyens de
produire massivement ces vaccins pour
l'ensemble de la population mondiale
l'émergence de variance c'est le plus
grand risque c'est ça le risque
aujourd'hui est le virus ne connaît pas
de frontières arrêtons de croire quand
on nous vaccinons dans les pays riches
on réglera le problème aujourd'hui on
vaccine que dans les pays riches
ça c'est un vrai problème de santé
publique
je vous fais l'erreur rebondir également
à pierre-jean permanent sur cette
question des écoles que vous évoquez
christophe prudhomme pour cela je
voudrais vous faire écouter jean michel
blanquer réunissent de l'éducation il y
a le coronavirus et la santé physique et
psychique de nos enfants l'école n'est
pas le lieu où on doit concentrer toute
notre attention sur les facteurs de
l'épidémie l'école n'est pas responsable
en soi de l'épidémie l'école
représentent une petite partie de ce que
représente la vie d'amy il n'y a pas de
contamination particulièrement
importante à l'école vrai pierre-jean
atteint magnan ça c'était un jean michel
blanquer le vin
5 avril entre temps nous a dit oui c'est
quand même peut-être contaminant les
enfants c'est vrai qu'il ya des allers
retours sur ce point qui croire une
bonne fois pour toutes aux à partir du
moment où le ministre annonce quelque
chose j'aurais tendance à le croire
parce que sinon c'est mais attendez je
plaisante je suis très très sceptique
sur ce qu'il annonce on n'a pas de
certitudes et je rejoins ce que dit mon
confrère le problème n'est pas là le
problème est que nous avons un retard
vaccination en france et il ya deux
piliers pour votre dîner il ya les
centres de vaccination et surtout la
médecine libérale
or sur la médecine libérale on dépend
d'astrazeneca la confiance des gens en
est rasé l'état s'effondre on a un
million cinq cent mille doses en stock
d'accord qui ne trouve pas preneur alors
que si vous regardez les stocks de
modern art où de pfizer c'est un stock
tampon de 150 mille doses
on a un vrai problème d'acceptabilité de
l'astra zeneca alors on nous explique
que johnson and johnson va remplir mais
c'est pas vrai puisque de te perds c'est
le même type d'année le virus atténué au
point de vue mode de vaccins donc le
problème que l'on a en france et je le
rejoins sur le fait que plus on aura de
retard à vacciner plus on a la chance
d'avoir une émergence de variants ça
c'est clair
or actuellement nous avons un patinage
alors c'est vrai qu'on ouvre les vannes
sur la vaccination
mais en pratique on n'arrive pas à
placer la stratégie cta ça représente
jusqu'à la fin de juillet août
pratiquement 35% des doses disponibles
en france comment va-t-on faire
c'est ça qu'on va t'en faire dans le
soutien certains pays du nord qui dans
un dernier pays s étaient hier qu'il a
qui l'a suspendu christophe prudhomme
votre collègue vous parle de la défiance
comment on va convaincre les parents
dans un second temps de vacciner les
enfants si les ja l'ensemble des
français adultes sont sceptiques
on voit bien que la la communication est
très importante en termes de santé
publique il faut obtenir la conviction
de la population ce qui se passe avec
astrazeneca est complètement irrationnel
les risques sont tout à fait modérées et
le fait qu'on ait un million cinq cent
mille doses disponibles comme c'est mon
collègue évoqué c'est un million cinq
cent mille personnes non protégé donc
des gens qui vont tomber malade et qui
vont mourir c'est ça qu'il faut lire le
risque de thrombose est tout à fait
limité on a des risques équivalent en
prenant l'avion en prenant la pilule
donc voilà donc c'est irrationnel la
communication des gouvernements
européens est catastrophique
aucune coordination chaque pays fait ce
qu'il veut dans son coin on a des
informations qui sont biaisés on affole
la population savait pour un cas pour un
cas de thrombose
ça fait la une des journaux toute la
journée sur vos chaînes d'information en
continu c'est quand même catastrophique
c'est par l'information ça donc
effectivement aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous voulez on a perdu la bataille sur
l'astra zellik avec la population donc
quand même quand on entend que la
norvège hier suspense ce sérum comme l'a
fait avant lui je voudrais pas dire de
bêtises c'était un autre pays du nord
peut-être la suède je ne sais plus
en tout cas hier c'était la norvège
c'est vrai que ça c'est pas les médias
français voient ya un vrai scepticisme
quant à ses services scepticisme est dû
au fait que chaque pays a commandé comme
ils voulaient ces vaccins et plus ou
moins avancés sur la vaccination
donc c'est un joyeux bordel quand les
gens ont effectivement suffisamment de
doses pour pouvoir vacciner leur
population avec un vaccin arn messagers
et bien ils disent ça suffit on n'a pas
besoin de l'astra zeneca et comme ça il
se protège c'est le principe de
précaution à l'infini mais le principe
de précaution à l'infini vous savez il
faut plus traverser la rue il faut plus
prendre l'avion
peut-être qu'il faut pas sortir parce
qu'un astéroïde risque de tomber vous
tomber dessus ou un morceau de la fusée
chinoise là qui s'est désintégré et on a
frôlé la population fin bref c'est
complètement irrationnel cette peur du
vaccin
quand vous prenez un comprimé de
doliprane efferalgan vous prenez aussi
un risque pour votre foi voilà il ya
toujours des risques dans la vie la
question c'est le rapport bénéfice
risque et quand on revient aux enfants
pour l'instant pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas de preuve que le bénéfice
est supérieur au risque pour une
population qui aujourd'hui ne fait
quasiment aucun cas grave de covin il ya
quasiment aucun mort chez les moins de
15 ans du co vide
on n'a pas plus de mortalité de là avec
ce corps là virus qu'avec le virus de la
grippe traditionnelle saisonnière chez
les enfants donc voilà c'est ça qu'il
faut voir rapport bénéfices liste en
permanence en tout cas là ce tracé n'est
qu'à ne concerne pas les les enfants
puisqu'il est réservé aux plus de 55 ans
en france dernière question jean pierre
magnan quel vaccin que justement
privilégiée pour ces petits celui de
files heures comment semblant prendre la
route
mais je crois que si vous voulez on il a
raison mon confrère on a raté la
communication on a raté la communication
de la gestion de la crise le rapport de
l' oms indépendant est accablant pour
nos autorités politiques et on a raté
nous en france la communication sur la
vaccination
faut quand même rappeler que notre cher
gouvernement s'est préoccupé de la
vaccination en octobre novembre
on était déjà en pleine situation de
pandémie au mois de mars dont il ya eu
un retard à l'allumage considérable le
deuxième point c'est que la population
était axé contre la vaccination et la
france est championne pour ça
pour dire maintenant sert pas à grand
chose en pratique c'est important or on
a réussi on va dire l'ensemble comme
unité médicale à convaincre la
population de se faire vacciner à partir
d'octobre et on est passé à plus de 50 %
d'une population
on a eu ce truc tout à fait irrationnel
de l'astra zeneca avec le rapport
bénéfice risque qui reste très bon mais
c'est le principe cher à nos politiques
n'est pas coupable je responsable le
sujet mais pourquoi donc on est
maintenant dans un schéma où les parents
qui refusent de faire l'astra zeneca il
dit je préfère un arn message in sont
les mêmes qui voulait autant que les
saluer çà va modifier mon vélo sur des
conneries n'était alors ok on va être là
mais en pratique si vous n'avez pas la
confiance des parents comment voulez
vous demain si vraiment c'est nécessaire
et pour l'instant ce n'est absolument
pas nécessaire vacciner des gosses le
problème c'est qu'on a perdu la
population française a perdu confiance
dans l'information qui est de véhiculer
sur la vaccination en fonction des
origines géographiques de fabrication et
c'est ça la difficulté
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
sergents interne damion et christophe
prudhomme d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france